well I mean one of the things that I
don't think anyone who watches the show
would believe is that it's really really
[ __ ] boring and that's not me being
facetious or in any way it's anyone
that's on it would agree mmm never get
to see 45 minutes 40 minutes out of the
day from mother that's the best bit well
yeah from multiple people's lives so
times up by 14 yeah so you talking like
what 350 hours of life so you've
probably got like a good bit every 24
hours
well it's more about your highlight it's
more about your experience it's not
about the not about the end result that
goes on TV it's more about what you
experience hmm well yeah yeah yeah okay
you would like to be really good baby
patois I was a cracking moment now yeah
cracking 30 second rise now let's get
back to the remaining like 23 hours you
know it's nerdi said no entertainment
but no because you've got no phone you
can't bring a book in couldn't bring
book in knocked or smart but they were
allowed to do gold who was the
born-again Christian on my series was
allowed to bring a Bible in and I
thought what I've got The Selfish Gene
Richard Dawkins any chance I could bring
this militant atheism no no no and so
yeah there's all the cameras around and
you are very conscious by say of what's
going on but very quickly also adapt to
the situation a lot of this stuff's done
behind one-way mirrors so there's a
mirror above the kitchen there's a
mirror in the girls changing rooms his
mirrors around and behind that there's a
lot of stuff that's going on as well
with cameras and stuff obviously that's
completely oblivious no wherever and the
little ones can just swivel around and
he kind of don't know you're always
miked up there'll be a sound guy coming
twice a day morning and night and change
your batteries out
so you think with a microphone on will
be enough to have it next to you bed but
the second you go even if you'll see oh
the bastard right on put it on and look
I'm over the tonight Christian got you
Mike Frato go but is it like a house
like an elastic band elastic balance
thing that's then got big you clip
thing on two and then that comes down
there yeah let me show one back on by
Mac but make the eval I can pretty much
at all times
which isn't waterproof so again just was
that it's worth like each one's worth at
250 quid so you gotta be waterproof bone
bag gap in the market we have 1414 sales
per year so yeah the the fact that
you've got to get 45 minutes of content
out of a full day inevitably means that
they need to push and hurry the story
lines along along so poke you with a
stick a little bit yes - they need to
make to get out they need to expedite
what's happening but they can't have 14
day wooing period where someone finally
cooks up the courage to ask me to hold
someone else's hands it needs to happen
now that's right how do they encourage
that we said when they take you aside
for example is that eliciting your
opinion or is it like oh do you wanna go
oh no no it's not it's more about its I
think everyone's conscious another thing
to consider is everybody's conscious
that they're there a lot of the people
there to get time on TV you haven't gone
on TV to not be on TV so what they term
producing content is doing something
which will make the Edit or doing
something which will contribute to the
Edit the final production of that
particular episode we're loving
just imagining how often Youssef would
be on the others alright I feel like it
would be constantly
so I'd imagine like let's say people
having a chart and then someone goes
like they'll have to be like okay chop
that use of surprised savers a file and
then like slip it into other
conversation so you is what they're
doing like x-factor for example where
they splice audience reactions with
things that didn't reacting to you redo
that minute but just chop in so I just
want though whenever we say something
they need a bank if like seven emotions
and we can just throw them in whenever
Chris furious Johnny nine story so
that's a good that's a really good point
about them noting stuff down actually
sort of alluded to them transcribing
things you will have someone listening
to your channel on the mic almost 24
hours a day and I came out there really
really weird so while I was in there the
majority of the conversations that you
have have to be about what's going on
and if you begin to talk about stuff
from the outside world common friends
that you've got that aren't in the villa
they'll come over the tamo and they'll
tell you islanders can you please stop
talking about the outside world thank
you really see you actually have more
freedom in most prisons then yeah like
you thought that's thought police I
thought every so Orwellian like any you
can it's you right it's when you say it
like that it sounds really terrible work
yeah so you can't there's no
entertainment you have to just be with
yourself and with the other people and
you can't talk about anything apart from
the inane activities very what everyone
else is doing without anything saving it
without them yeah this is what I mean
when I say they're exploring like it
it's some stupid to say that you're in
this ten million pound villa with
half-naked girls wait to read boring mmm
like you there's only so many times that
you can talk about Omar in that chat
that he had last night and how he proper
mugged or off the rug like how many
times can you say that because nothing
else has happened because there's a
reflection period you understand there's
these peaks of activity that are then
followed by an anger chamber of it
happening and once that's been completed
you need to wait for the next thing to
happen but
during that time you can only talk about
stuff that's going on in development
people drink alcohol so you I thought
when I went on I was expecting to be
likes on the beach or Geordie Shore had
a lot of experience of being around the
guys from geordie shore running club
night to Newcastle and I thought
brilliant days in the Sun nights getting
pissed this could be sweet got there and
you are limited to two drinks really
won't be a warm wine or any combination
thereof it's weird cuz it's like they're
trying to create this incubation chamber
but they're not putting any accelerants
in there either it's like I think what
to be honest the alcohol thing although
I've wanted to stop someone at the time
for the restrictions looking back I can
see why they do it because if you look
at the the groove that love islands
carved out for itself in programming
it isn't Geordie Shore into not X on the
beach it's not as a state classy it's
not as fluffy as something like Made in
Chelsea or TOWIE but it's not actually
all that far off when you look at it hi
introduction value everyone in there
yeah there's arguments and stuff like
that but it's not because someone's out
of control it's because of all the rules
in the tannoy
like no no alcohol no red foods no
cheese no mismatching socks like you
know frowned food touching beige for you
know you might [ __ ] I'd pee yeah
ruin terrible wound so yeah they want to
do one of the problems that you come
across is that you just bought like
you've got nothing to talk about and
then like you say you've restricted on
how many times you can talk about the
same situation but one of the things
that does happen like when they've when
they've got the content for the day
there's less truth a little bit less
pressure and because the live show on
the year that we did it was on a
Thursday night I think is either a
Thursday or Friday night knows a
Thursday night
what it meant was that there's no show
on a Friday in a reCAPTCHA on a Saturday
so you had Thursday's off completely and
that was complete that was liberation
you could do whatever you wanted and the
this little filming on Thursdays they're
still filming but what they say is look
guys just don't do anything don't do
anything exciting the cameras are
rolling but we don't want to put it in
so just as long as you guys are happy to
talk about back home and stuff like that
but you know six days a week if not
being able to do that is actually quite
quite right